[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احب ابشركم ان الامطار التي نزلت خلال هذه
الفتره منبته للربيع الشتوي واهم الامطار
الشتويه هي التي تنزل في اول الوسم
والعامه يسمونها بثروي نسبه الى نجمه
الثريا وثريه في انباتها واهم الامطار
الصيفيه هي امطار اسماك نسبه الى نجم
اسماك فهي منبته
لا تسقني ماء الحياه بذله بل فاسقني
بالعزي كاس الحنبلي ماء الحياه بذله جهنمي
وجهنم بالعزي
اطيب منزلي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والامطار تنقسم عندنا قسمين شتويه وصيفيه
الشتويه هي المومبته للربيعه الشتوي نبت
الناعم والصيفيه هي التي تنبت الربيع
الصيفي شجر خشن فاذا نزلت الامطار بسهيل
والوسم والمربعانيه والشبط فانها منبته
للربيع الشتوي واذا نزلت الامطار بل
العقارب والحميمين والاذرعه فانها منبته
للربيع الصيفي والربيع الصيفي اهم من
الشتوي عند اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم
وقالوا يا الله بصفيته نرعى بها حوليه ولا
وسميه النار بها
شتويه
[موسيقى]